oui il ya des chevaux cac un espèce de
thon autobiographique alors moi
maintenant de moi je leur dis vous êtes
vous êtes un amener du vol vos trois
mules voleurs de vélos 3 que c'est à
leur est pas si vous avez remarqué mais
michel audiard n'a pas bu une goutte de
vin alors nous on boit on s'est tu es
malade et je vais te dire il nous paraît
tête voir ses joueurs l'état et pièces à
nice les deux écoutes comme c'était le
cas ça veut dire la joue pas il ajouté
jean carmet se porte très bien et les
cheveux sur la tête voire à la suite
d'un dimanche ou lundi facettes avec mon
camarade sur les façades et un dimanche
à dourdan exigeant et on ya eu le
déjeuner y attribuer le soir on a remis
la table c'est ma femme a remis la balle
on n'avait pas quitté la table mais on
avait parlé de ranger qu'angers en a
parlé d' raimbourg n'a fallu partir à
charleville la vente on voulait
découvrir le maniement driver fois que
wade bonne ambiance et le lendemain
quand j'ai vu les cas la rallye est dans
la cuisine
j'ai été et tout vent s'est éjecté du
rhum non c'était le lendemain matin je
t'ai dit qu'est ce qu'on boit et tu m'as
dit rien alors il pourrait tendre de vue
le choix peut diminuer sur les ténèbres
à la normale cela continue comme ça on
va voir ce que ça va faire dix mois les
attaques de cuttoli à les bouteilles des
bouteilles je ne sais pas ao muer en
suisse en mai fallait fall a fait des
choses et je veux donner encore une
raison pour ne pas boire sa femme
admirable rencontrer l'autre fois une
saynète le fallait en prêt chez lui un
soir c'est la banda
s'acheter un bon il est monté chez lui
il s'est enfermé dans son bureau
elle a eu peur car dans cet état là ça
fait peur elle est allée regarder par le
trou chazel et elle a vu tiens toi bien
il fallait qu'ils se mettaient d'un côté
de sa table de travail qui parlait qui
discutaient qui faisait le tour de la
table à l'aide autre côté ce rêve tu vas
me dire que c'est dit il était dans son
état normal
dédoublement de certains artistes mais
c'est un artiste de tous les temps est
docteur jekyll et mr hyde on a discuté
longtemps
oui et puis on attend qu'ils s'en
souviennent et lendemain non leur accord
au fond pour pour conduire a du mal que
nous
un soir avec bath 11 pareil
les flacons avaient défilé mais me range
ce profit est un nom dans l'alcoolisme
sommes nous mêmes il opère vers 15h nous
donnent ils à faire en cachette et un
soir c'était un peu abîmée aussi et moi
c'est moi mais deux chanteurs préférés
c'est brassens et moi et moi mais cela
devrait bien se savent ou peu cuits
entendez par là mais sincère et non non
au cinéma ce que tu vois il va faire des
films encore ton roman ça veut pas dire
que tu vas tu arrêteras des films et non
une chance je voudrais alterné faire un
bailleur